amateurs de musique à vos écrans dès
aujourd'hui vous pouvez profiter d'une
série de concerts intimes de l'
orchestre métropolitain pour quelques
dollars via une plateforme web une
manière de renouer avec la musique
classique alors que les salles de
spectacles recommence tranquillement
leurs activités j'en parle avec le
maestro yannick nézet-séguin monsieur
nézet-séguin bonsoir bonsoir
alors parlez nous de cet été de
beethoven c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
ça c'est les huit premières symphonies
je pense de beethoven que vous avez
enregistrés et que vous diffusée sur
internet
d'où est venue l'idée pourquoi
l'avez-vous concrétiser dès le début de
la pandémie en fête et du confinement
quand on sait on a réalisé que toutes
les scènes allait être bon dans le noir
pour un bout de temps
mon équipe alors que se permet trop
brittain moi même on ne déjà mis des
plans en place pour se dire jusque quand
on aurait le droit de se remettre
ensemble donc ça s'est passé après trois
mois finalement de se remettre ensemble
pour des diffusions que le gouvernement
autoriser ce type de rassemblement tout
en n'étant pas publiques avec d'autres
histoires
on voulait refaire de la musique on
voulait capter ce moment alors on s'est
mis avec une équipe de caméras la salle
bourgie du musée des beaux-arts de
montréal et on a décidé de jouer du
beethoven parce que si les 250 ans de la
naissance de beethoven et on aurait dû
jouer un peu partout dans le monde
des oeuvres de beethoven et sa tombe est
évidemment ça mal tombé à cause de ce
virus et on a été de fil en aiguille
c'est devenu une plateforme web la
nouvelle plateforme web de gramophone
stage donc c'est une plateforme
internationale qui donne non seulement
accès à notre public ici à montréal puis
au québec et au canada mais partout dans
le monde à ses symphonies de beethoven
qui qui sont assez spécial parce que
justement jouer en distanciation l'isiq
donc qui porte d'entrée du moment dans
lequel on se trouve
bon pour une quinzaine de dollars ont
payé en actions mais dites moi parce que
en salle quand le spectateur est là en
salle une expérience émotive une
expérience sensorielle aussi avec les
sens la vue on vous voit jouer puis on
dirait qu'on touche à la musique puis à
louis qui est sollicitée aussi mais là
vous êtes sur le web et on est dans
notre salon et comment on peut revivre
cet ex comment vous faites pour nous
faire revivre cette expérience c'est
clair que là vivent donc la musique
vivante en salle 6 remplaçable n'importe
quelle expérience virtuelle pourra
jamais remplacer
cet ensemble de ce que vous venez
d'écrire qui tout à fait vrai d'être
heures en salle de concert
mais en attendant pendant qu'on pût hugo
qu'on n'a pas accès à ce grand plaisir
c'est bien pousser les idées numérique
un peu plus loin par exemple en ayant
huit caméras pour ses symphonies de
beethoven qu'on présente on a
l'impression de se promener à travers
leurs caisses métropolitaine
c'est très très dynamique anglais et que
ça transparaît ce que c'est une session
travail qu'on voit le sourire des
musiciens les regards complices alors sa
seule expérience quand même très
différentes que les précieux au concert
de façon statique et ben c'est une autre
façon d'aborder la musique de rançon que
plus est il parlez moi du piano parce
que vous allez aussi donné un concert en
fin de semaine au domaine forget un
concert où vous allez jouer du piano
dont vous a vu un image jouer du piano
au mont saint-sauveur en camisole on a
remarqué ça avec le danseur étoile
guillaume côté on est plus habitude vous
à voir avec une baguette dans les mains
qu'avec les touches du piano au dessus
sous les doigts experts nous pourquoi le
piano qu'est ce que vous aimez dans cet
instrument
ça a été mon instrument mois que j'ai
appris depuis que j'ai 5 ans et même si
j'ai voulu devenir chef d'orchestre est
jeune c'est comme pianiste que je me
suis formée et le piano c'est toujours
été un à-côté depuis que j'ai ma
carrière de chef d'orchestre offert à
l'occasion la musique d'ensemble de
musique en groupe de musique de chambre
et le confinement fort c'est ma force et
ajustements peuvent jouer plus de piano
parce que c'est ce que j'avais à la
maison ça m'a permis de renouer avec mes
racines
finalement et ça m'a offert retomber en
amour avec le piano qui est une une
forme finalement plus intime de faire de
la musique
que directeur d'orchestre et quand le
domaine forget à saint-irénée m'a
approché pour et avec des membres de
leur caisse des tripolitains et le
violoniste klaxons langue qu'on puisse
faire de musique de chambre ensemble
c'était la meilleure occasion pour moi
de dire oui parce que normalement je
suis tellement occupés à cannes elle
concerne l'egypte elle concerne aussi je
vous peut pas dire que c'est un avantage
qui confirme en vendent en mettant le
confinement disons que j'ai trouvé cette
cette beauté à renouer avec mes lacets
en terminant bima logements y sont
intégrés mais vous vous dirigez aussi à
new york à philadelphie ça se passe
comment là bas et ce qu'ils sont des
confinement est ce que pour la musique
comment ça se passe
non personne c'est de musique encore m'a
fait ce qu'on fait là presque trop
politesse est parmi les premiers hors
caisse en amérique du nord à pouvoir le
faire
c'est très triste c'est philadephie new
york on est un peu plus loin on regarde
ça met ensemble décès de faire des
projets déclare bd plan c'est comme on
l'affirmé napolitain mais disons que
aussi ce qui se passe aux etats unis
c'est un petit peu plus chaotique ici
alors je en attendant toutes mes
énergies à montréal attendant de
commencer aux états unis est la beauté
de l'internet c'est que tout le monde
n'importe où dans le monde peut se
brancher alors vous amis de new york et
de philadelphie peuvent le faire aussi
ce sera peut-être qu'il va faire yannick
nézet séguin merci beaucoup et on va
regarder ça avec intérêt merci et bonne
fin de semaine un grand plaisir que ça